nville starts off with Dennis guran he feeds it to
the point the first shot of the game is handled by
soken who's had some issues of his own as we've
been talking about give go n tries to swing it
over to ory a backhander goes wide Fabro following
up Dante Fabro on the second unit here's a shot by
nqu cought off by sokin a big save this one goes
past Andrews Lee Andre Ley tries to steal the
next pass instead it comes back inside the line
it's picked up by walr he makes the move around
O'Reilly shoots it not much on it and a save by
Sor 35 or more goals each of the last two seasons
and 19 already this year here Eng ball angles his
way behind the net taken there centered in front
it a good save there by Soros fit back to the
slot for Nelson for this long and a lot of it
a tough luck but look at him this is him tracking
look at his eyes all the way that's a really good
shot if you just focus on his head he's he's
one of those staple guys there on the island
one of Lamar's guys no question bar Trot has a
pretty Keen appreciation for him that rebound
kicks right to the slot cleared out of there by
carer to Mary hanging out at the line drives it
in hits the trailer calling for it is barzel this
is what barel can do he shoots scooped up by the
glove of ss that is one of those awkward Falls
that always has you holding your breath now up
come the Islanders with some open space spinning
around barzel stops on a dime a backhander stuck
by Soros that one left the Mark wasan still
down and hurting on the bench keep an eye on
that pelaris shot that's snared they defend
really well they're on you you don't have a
lot of time but you have to recognize that keep
in doson and here's a shot point off by sorrow
wber has not been quite as deadly at home as
he has been on the road not that he's been bad
here O'Reilly in the corner comes up with it
Carson in his in for for shines it up an easy
save for shro up the boards of angelista stops
draws the coverage into the slot for Novak eeds
it out for Fabro back for Evangelista looks at
the net drags drives it right along the ice and
soken able to make the stop with no rebound ranov
a goal two games ago an assist against out so two
points in three games as a predator here's barzel
swings it to the net bouncing puck in front guran
arrives just in time to take it away from Horvat
you see the creativity of barzel s shot rocker sa
soken retriev quickly right in front another
bang bang save it creates the play that nice
job on the rush here assistens on the outside bad
angle there's a a shot there and this starts all
the stuff right here comes around from the back
of the net gets another shot sistens was right
there in the low slot calling for gurianov and
a rising shot is snagged soken with the glove
fourth line again playing hard paron starting to
get a little more physical lately Nelson tried
to shoot it through lazan unsuccessful yeah
that's foundation of the Barry trots defense
no question about it trots from sweep drop pass
chin to the middle Cole Smith could not split
the two Defenders and it's taken by Paul Mary
saer pass horback he's behind the Deep horback
stop Point CL Soros with a big save Outlet pass
Smith takes it the other direction Smith lost
his balance got it back looks for help gy one
timer blocked Lov got a piece chased down by
Fabro was on sent it flying wide to the net
nist tried to tip it he had a good screen
back come The Islander from the slot save by
Soros watch this right here everyone kind of
get Shades over there big save there by
juice change direction terer the leading
shot blocker for the Predator set behind
the net for Paul Mary PA Mary one-on-one
muscles his way to the slot turnaround shot
sto by Soros barzel buzzing all over the
offensive zone Here Comes barzel again
Wheels it over Doon what Tyler off the
post Yosi Watson from the circle drives behind
the net on Martin Around the perimeter again
Fabro now on the near side that's tipped on net
saved by SRO back from the corner and this was
earlier this is more likely right there that was
that was a great play there just to the outside
Fabro just get that through good tip there
by McCarron a double tip R Puck racing over
gurianov whacked out of the air by Lee but it goes
to Gano goranov Lins up shoots soken able to the
hold pjo starts it straight line on the wing
pulls up some snow hits the trailer Romanov
around the hor save by Sor on CL feeds it out
hop stops him score it was tipped in front by
pjo and the Islanders are on the board backto
back turnovers by the predators in the neutral
zone and the second one proved costly a
tight hockey game like this it's one of
those mistakes SOS just makes an unbelievable
save here watch P look at the tip here this
gets through thomasino he doesn't get down
all the way he spread out here goes right
through the legs not quite in a great spot
to block a shot and then Pou with a really
good tip he was set up and that was a nice
play there Islanders a 29th rank penalty
kill but they've come up big so far tonight
17 seconds to go mcdna back to Evangelista
tried to go back past one more guy got it over
to thomasino Barry he'll try it again shoots
score Evangelista he drew the penalty and then he
scores the equal ey for on the power play this is
why you shoot the puck watch this right here
he's going to try to make a little play loses
the puck but he opens up gets back into position
he's taking shot all the way as soon as he gets
that and puts an absolute Dart right by the
defenseman over the shoulder under the arm of
shokin and he had no idea no back crosses right
in front of him and he still doesn't know where
that is Outlet pass n didn't hang on got it
to the red line and then back come the honors
cor back drives rounded there well save by Soros
rebound Lee s scles back doing some work one he
made about three more on this sequence to keep the
score tied at one picked up by Mark pass stolen
by forsberg tries to drive it in forsberg Waits
looking wrap around instead to lazan carier shoots
score yes sir 7.1 to go
a magical bounce on a Saturday night in smackville
carier Let it Fly and it fluttered over the
shoulder of soken the Islanders bench absolutely
dejected but the Predators they just wanted this
one forsberg looking for someone to give it to
everyone in front taking back to laon carry goes
out they try to block it right here hits the
Stick of Mayfield breaks it in half and then
it goes over the shoulder of sokin and look at
the bench what a big goal is this being reviewed
right now or what a massive goal time out Yosi and
MCD together Cole Smith on the ice as well with
yo Parson face off comes back towards Yosi Yosi
Scot it Parson in with the empty net he scores
but a job well this is finishing the job right
here Yosi just getting that
up bursting and Off to the
Races that'll assist for Yosi
as well and so that'll do it
dramatic win on a Saturday night
smashville and U Soros busts out
of a mini slop the Predators get a
big two points against the Islanders